hey guys i've got a question for you
when you look at yourself in the mirror
are you happy with what you're seeing
i wasn't
when i left school i suddenly started to
become
fat obese i didn't like it and i didn't
realize i started to do
everyday things habits that made me more
obese i started to gain a lot more
weight i didn't like what i saw
in the mirror at all so in this video i
want to share with you nine bad habits
that will make you gain weight check out
all of them to see if you're doing some
of these let's get to it
[Music]
just very quick if you're new here to my
channel my name is daniel and welcome to
dlm men's lifestyle now to lose weight
the first thing you need to do is to
look at yourself and be honest
look at yourself look at your lifestyle
and be honest about your bad habits and
then
stop them and replace them with better
good healthy habits let's take a look at
the list of bad habits that'll make you
fat
snacking too much
you know this was my thing i used to
come back home and then just get bags of
chips and then i'll watch good movies or
good tv series and you know how quickly
that bag of chips or few bags
of chips can just
disappear
why is because you're focusing so much
on what you're watching you're not
really focusing on how much and what
you're actually eating a study from the
university of birmingham shows that
people who are distracted
eat five to ten times more
and some people don't even remember
everything they ate now you gotta
understand this because even if you
snack on the more healthier options like
popcorn
beef jerky
or nuts if you do it too much those
calories they add up and you without you
even realizing it the next day you look
in the mirror and you're like woof what
happened to me i used to be athletic i
used to do sport in school now that i'm
out i'm working look at me i'm gaining
weight was because of your bad habits
thousands of guys come home they get
into this habit of just watching sport
or something with a lot of snacks and
beer and then you get fat you know what
i'm talking about snacking on chocolate
chips
ice cream
soda
beer
and before you know it you got fat test
yourself see if you can go without any
snacks for two weeks
eating too fast
have you ever tested yourself just to
compare yourself to other people while
you're eating in different settings with
different people how fast you're
actually eating
i did it the first time i did it i was
shocked because it's as if i saw myself
through other people's eyes
man i look like a glutton a study from
the university of rhode island found
that people who eat slower eats one
third less than people who eat fast why
well because it takes around 20 minutes
for your stomach to tell your brain that
it's full
so then you eat more if you're eating
fast all you got to do is just train
yourself to eat slower and chew your
food at least 20 times before you
swallow it
[Music]
always eating low-fat or fat-free food
this happens to a lot of people
especially to people who think that all
right i'm gonna start a new healthy
lifestyle and i'm gonna start to eat
low-fat and fat-free food so they think
they will lose weight but then the
opposites start to to happen and they
don't understand because after all they
are eating fat-free and low-fat foods
but you gotta listen very carefully to
what i'm saying now
low-fat and fat-free does not mean
sugar-free when the food industry
started to take out the fat from the
products i realized that people didn't
like it as much because it didn't taste
as good
so the solution
sugar they added sugar in so every time
when you go and you want to buy fat for
your low fat products look at it first
and look at the sugar content
not choosing low calorie foods
ask yourself do you even know what
you're putting inside your body do you
know the calories of the food that you
eat if you're choosing high calorie
foods day after day after day after day
and you force your body actually to eat
all that food because your body does not
need all that food so you're forcing
your body to take that food and like oh
i don't know what to do with this
because we have all the energy we need
all right so let's just store it so it
stores fat so you become more obese over
time so first you need to break this bad
habit and you need to learn how much
calories your body actually needs if you
want to have a normal body a healthy
body of an average guy with an average
height you need to consume the following
calories take a screenshot of this if
you have to but keep in mind this is the
calories you need to maintain the weight
of a normal healthy guy with an average
height
now just to give you an idea here i'm in
my 30s right so i need to consume around
2 700 calories
now just take a guess guess the calories
in one slice beef pizza
714
now that means if i just eat four slices
of beef pizza then i've gone over my
daily limit already
not getting enough sleep
now for you guys who've been around here
on my channel for a while you know i
talk about this a lot for different
reasons
the importance of sleep healthy good
sleep seven to eight hours
you know by now how crucial it is for
your healthy lifestyle and today we're
talking about it again why
why is not sleeping enough a bad habit
well if you don't sleep enough you don't
get the energy that you need right to
take on the challenges of the day so you
need that energy from somewhere else so
what do most people do
food
not sleeping enough makes you feel
hungry even when you're full
because sleep loss affects your hormone
cortisol which regulates your appetite
not only that sleep loss also increases
the fat storage in your body so guys
please listen to me and get good quality
sleep every night develop a good habit a
good sleeping
routine drinking something before
thinking and i'm not talking about just
drinking something like water no no i'm
talking about those unhealthy things you
know what i'm talking about
soft drinks coke sprite and beer
and even juice with sugar in it it's so
easy when it's a habit right because you
just take and you just chuck it down all
right and then you continue your day but
you forget how many calories is actually
in what you're drinking so you have to
break away from this bad habit even
better just stop drinking those soft
drinks because it really is
terrible for you apart from making you
fat it causes diabetes heart disease and
it puts a lot of stress on your pancreas
all right you get it you get the picture
right there's a lot of videos out there
check it out search it on youtube
there's a lot of videos on how bad these
soft drinks really are for your body and
you know we humans we complain a lot
these days a lot of people man my uncle
my aunt
this person that person they get cancer
they get diabetes but whose fault is it
most of the time it's our fault it's
because of what we put into our bodies
grocery shopping while you're hungry
you know what i'm talking about right i
used to do this a lot you know you're so
hungry at home but it's nothing to eat
so you go to the grocery store you want
to buy some food for home but when
you're there man you're so hungry you
want to eat everything and then the
unhealthy food oh man they especially
smell good and they look good and didn't
you just buy it and then you eat it and
then afterwards
you feel guilty you feel bad you don't
feel good and you gain weight
so try to eat something that is healthy
that fills you up before you go to the
grocery store
[Music]
big bites of food
i used to do this a lot
i used to like you know when i eat a
burger or pizza i just ah i like to take
big bites but then before i knew it it
became a bad habit and i didn't even
realize what i was doing later on the
american journal of clinical nutrition
shows that if you take big bites of food
you're consuming around 50 percent more
calories than people who take smaller
bites and chew it longer so all you
gotta do is cut your food into smaller
portions so then when you take bites
it'll be smaller as well another trick
that you can do is just to use smaller
plates and silverware so then you take
less food and you eat less food you know
here in south africa we have this
culture of eating a lot we've got big
plates a lot of food and
you can't waste food
from from a young age you're taught
you can't waste that food or else you'll
get a spanking a hiding but i learned
something when i worked in asia japan
china korea most of those countries when
they eat
they use smaller plates silverware
smaller so they consume smaller portion
sizes
bad habit of not forcing yourself to
change i can stand here the whole day
and give you all the advice that i know
you can watch thousands of videos on
fitness on health and nutrition but if
you don't force yourself to do it
nothing is going to happen if you don't
want to change if you don't want to put
in the effort if you don't want to learn
to work out and to eat healthy it's not
going gonna happen i did a
transformation video with my brother and
i helped a lot of people to lose weight
and the number one thing that stops them
from achieving their weight loss goals
is not the diet plan or the workout
routine
it is them we are our worst enemy it's
what's going on in your mind up here
if you have a bad habit of just always
staying in your comfort zone nothing
will ever change
you will not change listen carefully if
you can control your mind you will also
control your body
i heard this quote somewhere nothing
will work unless you do
this is so true
not only is it true of your goals for
weight loss but with everything you do
everything you take on all the goals you
have in your life
you got to respect yourself enough to
change today because the you of tomorrow
will thank you for it and listen when
you think about your health it's not
just about the weight that you lose
it's about the life that you gain
so remember life is short
so don't waste yours
cheers guys